on observe une augmentation euh très
marquée des des des violences de tout ce
qui quelque part symbolise l'État de
droit le le le le l'ordre le l'économie
euh l'autorité euh et et pour le coup on
a c'est c'est c'est des choses que l'on
observe qu'on a observé en de manière
assez importante en 2023 avec des
contestations qui sont de plus en plus
hétérogènes avec des des CSP euh dans
dans les gens qu'on interpelle on a
absolument de tout je vous donne un
exemple en région
lyonnaise alors d'une manière générale
les les atteintes au relais de 5g sont
sont assez classiques avec des discours
la 5G c'est le mal ça donne ça donne
plein de
maladies puis la terre est plate et puis
on a quand même arrêté des moines qui
ont attaqué un relais
5G donc tout peut arriver
euh et et alors on na jamais eu
réellement l'explication de du passage à
l'acte mais en fait on observe malgré
tout qu'aujourd'hui entre les réaux
sociaux le fait algorithmique qui fait
qu'on que que vous n'avez sur sur les
réseaux auquels vous vous connectez que
les informations qui vous intéressent ça
ça exacerbe en fait certaines certitudes
que que l'on peut avoir on a de plus en
plus de gens qui considèrent que la
terre est plate et comme vous n'alz
regarder que les informations qui
concernent la Terre plate le les
algorithmes vont vous donner ces
informationsl et du coup on a des
communautés qui sont qui sont de plus en
plus fortes où la fin du monde est pour
demain on a eu plusieurs cas de de gens
qui ont tué leurs voisins leur et qui
ensuite ont voulu se faire tuer par des
policiers ou par des gendarmes euh et
ces phénomènes là on les retrouve assez
facilement je veux pas faire de
sociologie de comptoir mais la crise
sanitaire a amplifié encore les
fragilités avec des gens qui ont arrêté
de se soigner et aujourd'hui on a pareil
le le le le je dirais le le truc assez
classique c'est l'homme qui bat sa femme
quand les gendarmes interviennent il
tirent sur les gendarmes on a
globalement toutes les deux nuits les
gendarmes qui sont tirés
dessus toutes les 30 minutes on a une
voiture qui fond sur les
gendarmes et quand on en arrête quand
même beaucoup mais on peut foncer sur
les gendarmes parce qu'on a plus de
point ou parce que on se dit on passera
à
côté le le la
légitimité et le
en fait il y a une forme de
désinhibition et que que l'on retrouve
un petit peu partout je vous donne un un
autre exemple et je m'en arrêterai là
saint Soline j'ai entendu de nombreuses
fois y compris dans les médias le
certains m'ont dit mais si vous n'aviez
pas été là il y aurait pas eu de
violence c'est imparable c'est imparable
c'est vrai que si entre les bassines et
les gens qui les black blocks que l'on a
observé s'il pas eu de gendarmes pour le
coup il y aurait pas de violence en tout
cas entre les black block et les
gendarmes faute de
gendarmes et mais en fait ce discours
est considéré comme légitime par
beaucoup et je vous passe moi les gens à
qui je fais des remarques sur la route
dans Paris qui roulent n'importe comment
ù un moment où en fait ça leur paraît
surprenant que je puisse leur dire que
ce qu'ils ont fait est interdit